what is up everybody it's an amount here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
episode of rant cafe rant cafe 31
everybody and this if you're new to the
channel this is a weekly podcast that we
do here at anime uh pro where we discuss
all things anime with a bunch of guests
including other youtubers and others and
speaking of which for the first time
today on rant cafe we have soul maka
joining us a known anime a rogue a
artist is what I'm going to call him and
also a really cool guy who is very
active on our discord server if you're
not on the anime upper discord server
you can check it out in the description
very act to this core server I've never
been part of more active discourse ever
I don't know about the rest of you guys
buy a soul welcome to the show thanks
thanks Anna Mike and yeah hi guys you
should all know me by now if you don't
then hello welcome my name is soul maka
I'm gonna ask and I am crazy into anime
and manga and I'm always on discord
you'll catch me there
we'll have deep debates over any anime
or manga that you're into feel free to
hit me up anytime on there yeah and we
now have a special chat for anime
theories on there for anime news so a
lot of stuff is going on and also
joining us today we have anime recon
what's up bro what up my boys I am back
well I've been here last week so yeah
but we're back again for life and I
enjoy this a lot yeah absolutely always
a great time and also joining us as
bricks from all day Anna Mae Briggs sup
guys hey hello hi and by the way always
[ __ ] you yeah Briggs Briggs that wasn't
the best intro but we still love you
Cheers by the way after I dropped the
whole anime rap cypher challenge both
anime recon and old anime drop their own
raps which was awesome great job for
them for responding after I tagged them
that's a sign of respect
so yeah respect rose much
preciate my favoritest and yeah so today
I was thinking for today's topic and we
always have different topics that we
talk about every week and for today's
topic I was thinking about talking about
anime we love to hate so anime that we
just love to hate on that are popular
and yet we hate on them whether it be
sword art online or in the chat
mentioned the Dragon Ball franchise or
Naruto one-piece whatever it is so you
know the popular anime that we all love
to talk about how bad they are
or aren't they really that bad in the
first place I want to talk about that
kind of stuff so are these anime really
that bad or it's just they're so popular
and overhyped then there's like a chain
reaction where people might know this
stuff sucks so yeah I want to talk about
that and I know recon has specific
tastes he's one of those guys that
doesn't have her own life it's good that
we have him here because we want to get
into this we want to hear from all sides
of the story and just want to say that I
think this last rank of a we got like
6,000 new subscribers on this channel
which is [ __ ] insane that is insane
that that was lastly guys I don't even
know what to say so so grateful both me
and goes in it's insane guys thank you
so much on them go ahead we go uh just
before we get things started we all know
the news the hype news that came out
today if you guys don't know
Shogo geeky no soma food wars see
they're season 3 has been announced
today so are all excited I know I'm
excited I cannot wait to get to that
food orgasm you know I cannot wait to
get to that poo Yasim awesome I didn't I
didn't hear this news yet so thank you
for breaking out enter you can I'm gonna
have to talk about that in the weekly
news that we do on Tuesdays because I
didn't hear this yet anyone else excited
for food or season 3 I'm super excited
it's actually my favorite series
surprisingly no no really cuz I'm just
reading the man gonna attempt to uh with
with certain series when I get like into
the mangola I do not watch the animes
unless it's like certain good scenes or
good fights or something like that that
I want to see then you know I'll check
it out
generally I tend to just focus on the
manga other than dynamite all right with
one why do I see Maria Eddings in the
chat I haven't seen you in a while Maria
you've been here for a long time since
like two case absque Rai burs I think
and she says [ __ ] Death Note she doesn't
like Death Note I actually love this
note but some people do say that it's
overhyped but it's not that big a deal
that is just you know uninteresting
conflicts between two people but not
really anything beyond that that people
look too much into it so that's an
interesting point
we also Armand are alert in the chat I
think he should be busy thinking how to
defeat the Titans personally but that's
just me but okay that's cool we got
Kevon Josh Luna all-day anime in the
chat egg hahahaha Josh jothee yeah let's
welcome to run deep voice a case newly
person a Robert Sufjan what's up
everybody
so yeah oh is that a noise in the
background
China is probably me oh okay I killed
her a little bit here a little bit
by the way soul and recon are both in
England so it's like 11:00 p.m. so here
in England I didn't know that yeah I
already told you man I told you I'm in
Leeds in ER what you're living leaves as
well yeah I already told you this is
home saying bro
we need to me I didn't know you did not
tell me that we need to I did I hope for
in the chat we need to meet up yeah yeah
that's right that's right no problem
yeah that's finally finally a fellow
youtuber lives where I am finally yeah I
know it's like yes like a I don't know
how in the middle or no way I kind of
see II but yeah yeah we do exist we do
exist
that's the Billy Superman what's up man
lock shot eren yeager dog says does
anyway everyone know about the death
Knoll Netflix live-action yes there's
going to be a
no Netflix produced live-action film
coming out later this year and that we
had a trailer for it that what did not
seem stellar if you guys got an opinion
on that let me know in the comments but
yeah I personally was thrown off a bit
by the trailer because it looked very
Americanized very like cheerleaders and
and stuff like that you know so it I
don't know I don't know if they're gonna
be able to adapt but also light the guy
playing life had blonde highlights which
I don't know man it's just not the kind
of lightly light picture but well it for
me with the deaf no I would prefer the
if as it changed its setting to light us
I would prefer it if it changed
everything else to suit a us setting
rather than you know trying to keep
certain Japanese aspects in the USA and
just yeah it feels odd mm-hmm lightening
darkness in the child so yeah I don't
know man you'll see right so you raise a
good point because he if they're gonna
change the setting then they have to
make it appropriate to this setting
otherwise it won't make sense but
there's two ways of doing that you can
do that the right way or you can do that
the wrong way and so far you know making
it Seoul Americanized with like to um
you know cheerleaders and stuff like
that highlights I don't know but we'll
see I'll give it a chance
why do i double the rebel general strike
on back to congratulate us on 26 k keeo
the good work double the level we aren't
seen you in a while maybe it's just me
maybe I missed you but welcome back and
thank you so much for your support as
always you're a good dude hmm alright
then um shall we guess that's really
love so much so yeah well just start if
you guys want to get into the pub okay
anime we love Kate Kate if anyone wants
to start recon you see me anxious
please go on Anna Anna you don't have ID
articulately
jump in first just to the family don't
really want to jump in first
how will I rip on SEO and then you can
jump in after sure it makes sense think
all the anime why don't you like Sao let
us know I feel like that I don't like it
I'd love to rip on
sayo mainly because I did enjoy it so
much in the first three episodes and
then it just annoyed me how they messed
up so like it was still a decent show
like it was it was I wouldn't say it's
as horrible as most people make it out
not as horrible as I make it out to be I
make it out to be complete trash but um
what's it called I just like it's
because I was enjoying it and I thought
it had a lot of potential that I love to
make fun of it and especially since it
had so much hype and there's so many
people that like like Adam a recon who
will defend it like to their death that
I just makes itself so fun about like a
topic to make fun of I could go on like
for a very long time to tripping on
certain plot points but mainly because
like I thought I had potential to be
good it's rigged essay was really one of
my first like one of my first 10 anime
series that I've ever watched like I've
watched of other 10 but Sao was also
part of it I really enjoyed the series
Briggs I don't know why you hated did
you read the manga I did not read the
manga I just watched the anime I don't
get why you hate it it has so much
action the romance between my great boy
Kirito and my girl
Isana who has she has incredible cooking
skills how can you hate on that there
was this insane amount of action the
story the plot everything was just
amazing
within this I don't know why people hate
I know people just hated the first
season I don't see a reason why but then
the second season came out and it all
just went from being sword action
fantasy into gun Gale online and that
was I think that was an incredible
change I was like damn now with guns
let's epic so my thing is sorry continue
if you want no it's fine go ahead
my thing is the first 12 episode so the
first three episodes were very good that
you got introduced into this new world
I'm a gamer myself so I thought it'd be
really cool to be immersed it was my
first time watching like stuck in a RPG
MMO like now I've seen a million of them
but it was it was a very new experience
and it was so hype it was the first
three episodes were very well about
introduced in the world the problem was
that um I cried I believe it's called or
like that first 12 episode ever world
that is it whatever game it was
only lasted 12 episodes and that I they
went through like 75 floors so they were
time skipping left and right
I found that like that's what my problem
was attack on Titan in the beginning was
people were dying left and right and I
just didn't care about them and I felt
like they could have taken the time to I
developed like the characters like I
remember I don't know what episode it
was where people were dying that like he
was like playing with like a lower level
like clan I guess and like I just didn't
care about their deaths I didn't
remember their name I can't remember
their names right now and I felt like
they could have turned those 12 episodes
into a 24 or 48 episode series and just
focused on that like that main story
instead they rushed immediate 12 episode
and then moved on to some other trash I
don't know like I just like it had a lot
of potential and you got no development
out of like Kirito because of all the
time skips no development of side
characters the romance was actually
decent I don't want to rip on the motor
oh man saying it's like so fake like
they're in a video game how do you
expect it to be I don't know that's the
one thing I won't make fun of is the
romance I think it looks alright I mean
they're in a virtual world they're not
in the real world so of course the
romance they're they're not they they
act as if they're married but they're
not actually married but but it was
really well no mommy I thought that
world is wilted a minute that is yeah
well their world is real Tim yeah
because they're stuck there so they they
have to do something about it yeah I
mean just like in some Eric smiles and
the chat says Pokemon is a bad anime
talk about it now Pokemon I thought it
was good when I was a kid but it's it's
like very immature it's for a young
audience for children so you grow out of
it so I think I kind of expect certain
anime to be geared for children pokemon
digimon right like so i don't
necessarily hate on it because i feel
like that's not for me that's for
children it's specifically made for
children Sailor Moon - that type of
stuff right so you know I expect that of
them and then Caliph said he hates
Naruto but he loves äôt now I don't
really care for now Naruto but obviously
I love attack on Titan but I think it's
because with me
maturity level of maturity is a big deal
in anime so that anime that
actually time to like have a lot of
maturity their deal with serious issues
there's a political context you know the
real world there is a death is happening
like you know there's real consequences
for actions so I think that's what to me
makes a great anime as opposed to
anywhere you know the hero never kills
anybody everyone that dies comes back to
life or doesn't die or whatever so that
to me I think is one of the things that
makes a great anime versus an okay anime
for me and in that spirit I think that
sword art online actually starts off
very well like I really like the set up
or art online they start off stuck in a
game a cool world game where if they die
in the game to die in real life so it's
a real consequence right it's not just
you don't just come back to life
at any time like you know re0 or
whatever you want to what other examples
you want to use so I think it starts off
as a great concept and even the pacing
is not bad like I liked the action
there's a drama there's good pacing
especially in the first season I thought
then we have the second season with that
weird like sit little sister stuff that
I was unnecessary but okay again happen
Don Gale I also enjoy and I know a lot
of people say that Kirito is a
overpowered protagonist and they don't
like him cuz of that I personally I
think he's not he's a one-dimensional
per darkness he doesn't have made much
you know he's not that interesting
however he's still better than a crybaby
protagonist I personally prefer an
overpowered protagonist to a crybaby
protagonist because I just can't relate
to private protagonist but the thing
with the where I really noticed a pacing
issue in sort out online was that last
arc where Asuna becomes the main
character that to me seemed to be kind
of unorganized all replaced the pacing
seemed to drag however I don't think the
show is as bad as some people make it
out to be I just don't think it's great
it's just something to watch but not
necessarily something to remember oh I'm
gonna get back to you yeah yeah yeah
yeah my force on Sao basically I liked
the first half of that first season in
it you know where ends where he ends up
recovering waking up whatever that was
all good
that was good
x2 romance like the confession the
as-sunnah makes to the old guy did they
did they went fishing with and stuff oh
yeah that that Willie set the tone for
how will their relationship was yeah
ma'am and then he wakes up he's got the
sister cousin girl that he's living with
and at one point he basically turns to
her and says oh well I can't answer your
feelings until I get Asuna buck and for
me that was like how the hell can you
say something like that
like she's even got a chance when you
know full well
Asuna is the only one for you yelling
that Willie turn me off because I like
parents so that really turned me off and
then with the gun girl arc with the um
was it laughing coughing coming back
again it just felt like wow okay so we
can't progress past this it's the same
guys again yeah men isn't laughing
coughing such a cool name and antagonist
like me and goals and both thought it
was such a cool thing like laughing
coughing and these guys like I wanted to
know more about them personally I I know
laughing coughing did return but the
thing is they hit it - well I mean his
name was defconn of course but we didn't
know until like closer to the very end
when kids will finally realize that this
guy is I think I don't know his name I
think his name was red-eyed zaza like um
for about four episodes and also they
started mentioning laughing coughing
yeah laughs I was that scene where I
think she was or he was sniping from the
bridge he'd caught like three guys or
four guys a bridge and he was killing in
there and then uh that that girl karma
burning the sniper girl she was there
none uh yeah and then I think can we
talk ran in the fighting and then I
think it was from there that he realized
that he was a like a laughing coughing
member because of something he did like
some kind of
action he did so because he realized the
connection to a ironclad that he would
only be able to do that or he would only
do that because of iron cried them and
you know they made the connection to
laughing coughing them so yeah yeah what
did you guys think of the Alpha online
basically all visited three games if it
is a sorta online a none crowd they went
to Alfheim online and then they went to
gun Gale online so which one is your
least favorite out of those three my
problem with this stuff is that after
the first time where they get stuck and
almost died it seems ridiculous they
keep going into these games yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's kind of a nerd over
say it's unsafe someone's dying
oh no so my bad candy snacks on this
unsafe I swear down okay yeah I mean
yeah it's kind of stupid
but yeah yeah I mean that's I mean
though it feels it feels okay but it
feels like we can't get past this like
it always has to be this and for me when
we got to gun girl which is my least
favorite to your question week on but me
that was like it killed it more they was
still like the same kind of enemy
laughing coughing again it was just like
wow we really haven't progressed even
though like you could make out that okay
they're dying now because some other
reason they're making it you're dying
now because of the same guys from the
first one
yeah means it's like wow okay well no
progression a lot of people in the in
the comment section are saying that alo
was the was the worst part and yeah I do
agree it wasn't that great gonca was
great but gun deal has to be probably
one of my favorite ones just because I
thought it was an action I was there
yeah I would agree with you I think it's
a cool twist and I did I personally like
gun gale the whole concept I don't know
why they made character so feminine that
was more like just you know to make him
into a trap for just a trope basically
was there wasn't any real reason but I
liked I liked the the show that arc the
concept by the way shout out to read you
mind the Chad Jojo talks too much is in
the chat what's up guys ghosts talk
our Master of Puppets familiar faces
welcome guys we had a lot of comments in
the chat I want to address a few of them
one of them was about one punch man and
one Podge related to that a high school
of the dead because I said that I tend
to like mature anime so people were
asking well do you like these anime if
you like my training I actually do like
these animals so like Keijo for example
but I like them for what they are I like
them for being comedies for being funny
for making fun of themselves and the
genre in the process and for just having
like you know you know what they are and
you take them for what they are and they
know what they are they're conscious or
what they are they're not trying to take
themselves too seriously and for that
you can appreciate they're not shows
that you're necessarily gonna think this
is the greatest show of all time however
you definitely have a good time watching
it laugh laugh a lot and that's what I
tend to find with these type of show so
I appreciate them so they're definitely
not shows that I hate on um something
else was mentioned about the whole um
now I'm losing am losing track there was
another animated someone brought up high
school the dead yeah high school that I
mentioned again I liked it for what it
is I know that it's uh oh yes
the harem aspect of sword art online
that is I think a legitimate criticism
because Kirito and the whole different
girls he meets it seems contrived very
contrived because he seems to be such a
good fit with Asuna from the beginning
and then they just throw in random girls
in there as love interest even though
you know we're not buying it because we
feel like you know he really he belongs
with astronaut like you know they have
the real connection all these other
girls seem to be just like unnecessary
and unlike something like Clannad where
I feel like the horror master gets done
right you actually feel like these other
girls are characters they're interesting
or you know even are easy ro as much as
you know we argue whether Amelia or Ram
our best girl we both think that we
think that they both are interesting
characters that they there's a reason
why super might be interested in either
of them with
on a line they seem to just throw a
bunch of girls at you and then it's like
it's almost like why like you know your
sin known you have the sister you have
the girl who makes the swords in the
original right Arden's meth yeah in like
three others and it's like why like
here's what I'm gonna say what I didn't
like about the that when they introduced
those new girls that being Lisbeth and
um silica once what's keratin was done
with these girls I mean we haven't then
they just like completely forget about
them
exactly then they just I everything is
being lose track I agree with you Anna
Mac but when Kyoto was done these girls
are just not like they're they're not
shown in the anime until like the very
very very end when they get jealous as
they see Kitty to an asana together
that's what like the next time they
appear within the series that's what I
didn't like it's like they throw these
characters in and just like two to one
episode and then they get away they just
disappear they're not there anymore
that's what exactly that's my whole
point it seems unnecessary right I know
agree to flow from the story sciency
that's exactly what I was saying as well
like they only have 12 episodes in that
first art and like four or five girls
were introduced like they had no time to
have any chance or to like us to care
about them at all or have any amount of
development for them it was just like
they were thrown in just to like be
there I don't know I thought the first
12 episodes was turned into a longer
series and they gave every character
more time and actually took their time
going through like the levels or
whatever and not just like time skip
after time skip I think would've been a
lot better
yeah the movie was also done pretty well
I actually agree cuz so you haven't seen
it with him I'm not gonna spoil it then
I can't talk about it oh yeah I have to
see yourself and I'm really interested
to see what it's about but I do get you
know after a certain point it's like why
do they keep getting into these games
that are clearly dangerous like per
charge like seriously like I understand
you know the first one and then he needs
to rescue astana and stuff like that
makes sense but then and then okay Gahan
gale they you know they need him in
there to help um cuz he's the best
player from the other game and they need
him to help stop a guy who's really
murdering people
so it's like okay I get it but then
after that it just seems like why it
seems unhappy rational um imperialist
opinions in the chat I want to say what
up to him and Jojo talks too much agrees
with me finally someone that agrees with
me the K Joe is a total blast from start
to finish we have a bunch of plebs like
all day anime who started watching
asteroid the new and finish it I was
doing but really yeah I got bored after
like two episodes obviously that there's
some actual cool people like Jojo talks
much to appreciate the hilarity that is
K Joe and also gorgeous grammatic who
changed his name recently said that he
the field he feels that one punch man is
everything that's wrong with Dragon Ball
the anime and I think that's cool like
that's an interesting perspective
because yeah one but Ryan definitely
pokes fun at all the tropes and if you
look at the very first villain in one
punch man that appears in the first
episode
he's a purple piccolo essentially right
so it's absolutely a direct reference to
Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball and so I
know Briggs I don't know why you didn't
like K Joe do you not did you not enjoy
the epic fanservice of boobs and butts
within that series you know I'm all for
boobs and butts and some good comedy but
like guys come like I found it funny I
have he did find it really funny but
after two episodes I had enough of it I
was good know someone laughs as a matter
of Briggs you're too good for fans there
isn't room good sophisticated for fans
ah dad I think I'm above it all you know
yeah I need something a bit more you
know some some real plot not like just
upper half of a woman's body plot but
you know real well yeah yeah and even
real applies you know like Master moose
Mazar snake tail anything real plot yeah
what what yeah why don't you guys go in
like watch a Shakespeare play like [ __ ]
alright a bit that done that yeah who
wants to talk about school days I have I
don't know how hated on you know cuz I
actually liked it it is a popular anime
but so many sequel hey me people hate it
yeah and it because mad hey I know it's
all because of the main character the
main character is what ruined the series
completely yeah he was here he was like
I mean in the manga he wasn't that bad
he will he wasn't but for some reason
with the anime they just made this guy
go like off the wall like he like once
ones like he's a pataga opened up that's
it he was like non-stop eating yeah I
mean it was just like oh you can eat
buffet you just lapping them all up like
his head yeah that's crazy
that was crazy it did like make you kind
of desensitized to caring for the guy at
all um and then I don't know I don't
understand
then why people would hate it though cuz
I mean if this guy acts like a dick and
then you hate the guy cuz he's a dick
then if he ends up dead why are you
gonna be bothered ain't you gonna cheer
and you're gonna go yeah good this dick
is finally dead
yeah him I don't get that yeah man I
really don't get the thing about the
main character in school days like he
falls in love with a girl and then he
moves on to another one and then he
moves on to another one and then he
moves on to another one it just shows
that he [ __ ] cares about himself he
even made a girl feel bad about herself
p.m. the female girl I forgot what her
name was
but and oh I just I just I [ __ ] hate
the main character of school days this
is what ruined the series completely for
me but I would still say I kind of
enjoyed it but then at the very end he
died and did you know what I said in the
end I was so glad he died okay check us
he died yeah like yes I can't exactly so
that's I mean so why why would you hate
on it like I don't get cuz I mean this
guy he makes himself out to be a
complete like [ __ ] you don't like this
guy you like oh my god I wish someone
would do something I really would song
with and then eventually someone does
son to him so then that's like yeah okay
you know I'm happy it said it's complete
yeah when and I mean I liked katana
hawkers in that series she never
actually did anything wrong
unlike like sekai cuz like ii knows okay
he's with this girl but she still went
after the guy anyway
yeah I mean so katana Hall was always
honest the whole way through in it you
know she ended up like mentally broken
because I like what went on and stuff
and then she ended up taking him back
whatever um so for her I was rooting for
her more so yeah me and then she got
like like her like reward in a twisted
sense I guess but yeah I mean so for me
it was him to win win he died she got
her goods and you know and that's it
then oh yeah it was Scott Cawthon aha
yeah that yeah yeah big titted girl yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just bailed on her
he guided him so much you know yeah that
broke my heart that scene way she ends
up sleeping with his friend that was
like all those too much and then she
comes out the classroom with a clothes
who like messed up and she sees him
dancing around the bonfire for the bomb
festival with a sec I thought yeah that
was that oh my god I honestly haven't
seen this show and after hearing this I
have no interest whatsoever yeah yeah
you would have liked it is very uneven
Ella
Jessie I like I like sure like I like to
show daily lives of high school boys
I enjoyed that show this one days thing
not liking it at all you're just gonna
see the main character dime you're
probably gonna be like yes he finally
died he deserved what he was getting
because of course sec guy she ends up
being a yonder at the end which I didn't
even realize that she was a yonder in
the first place until she exposed
herself at the end and then that boat
scene though what did you think about
but the boat sings on marker yeah i'll
fortunes crazy Donna already lost her
mind before that anyway yo like what you
got Wendy like broken and then she took
him back to then what's she talking back
he just went like off-the-wall yandere
yeah I mean she was like oh gee
she went crazy and then the way how she
dealt with sekai after and she's like
yeah see you're lying there's nothing
inside you
yeah I mean that was like okay yeah -
yeah she's lost it the bits and pieces
of her body and she was like hugging his
head all right good all right fellows
yeah crazy blonde we should move on
hey I hate harem series like infinite
stratos because with infinite stratos
when that came kind of like the big K on
my way frickin influx loads of these
harem series with the same kind of setup
started coming out like a hundred and
that Bahamut one you know the guy with
the unbeatable frame thing yeah all
those there were all kind of the same
thing one one solo guy in a school or a
place surrounded by women he's the only
guy generally and for some special Regis
reason he's like accepted there and it's
just like the reason would change for
each series yeah I mean but it's always
the same kind of thing and then who the
girls are attracted to him in it was
just that yeah okay born yeah like for
that type of stuff I there's a more
specific genre that I enjoy but I feel
like for anime I I don't see the point
shoutout to [ __ ] Mario always enjoy
some users are started Mario 64 Oh Marco
asked have you talked about era manga
sensei and again this is an anime to
watch because I have zero interest in
lolly stuff i I never got that fine to
it it's really what I've seen it's only
lollies so I was like nah no thanks not
my thing but I don't know if you guys
have a opinion on that if anyone seen it
I've seen it I've watched them yeah I
got it is Molly's but is it's so it's so
beautiful it is honestly so beautiful I
don't know this is why this is why this
is nothing there's nothing there's
nothing weird about a brother and sister
relationship there's nothing weird about
that there absolutely is they're not
what they're not blood so it's okay or
not they're not blood related
no but you know yeah yeah most a lot of
anime series it's brother and sister
relationship so yeah like a slight
problem with it but kiss XS is all no
they don't do anything weird don't worry
they don't yet no no she wants to though
I want to know what
okay I see yes buddies he's being a more
sensible brother I guess oh yeah it's
not like a sexist way you know that
cater guy is just like now experimenting
with these sisters so yeah okay Luda
brought up Yuri oh nice and that's a
show that people love to hate yeah I
personally have no interest in it so I
haven't seen it but I talk a lot you
hate it and I'll tell you why even
without seeing it I'll tell you that the
big reason people want love to hate it
is because it has such a insane fan base
not all of them obviously but there's a
aspect of the fan base that is so crazy
that people just get like a reaction
like a defensive reaction to it so for
example big example is the crunchyroll
Awards um where you know people just
spam voted you realize winning
everything and then fans of other anime
that didn't spam vote they thought this
was gonna be you know a fair thing where
there are anime could have a chance even
if they might have liked you're a nice
they just started hating it because of
the fans and how the fans behaved also
we had people like some urea noise fans
calling the anime man homophobic because
he didn't like the show and my crazy
[ __ ] like that and because of those
types of fans a lot of people now are
just have a gut reaction to dislike here
you're nice not necessarily because the
show itself but because of the way some
of the fans are acting and I think those
people need to really get it together
because you are doing a huge disservice
to your own show because it's becoming
the favorite show to hate on because of
your behavior not because it's
necessarily bad in itself so but I think
that's an interesting example there yeah
it's definitely it's definitely like a
response mechanism to how people carried
on with that show I definitely say that
I'm just gonna say this right now if you
watch Yuri on ice let's say a guy
watches it you're not gay you're
considered gay I don't think I don't
think anyone was just saying you're
automatically gay is something this I
assume that I don't know is that the
same can be said about boku no kokoro so
I'm pretty sure many people have watched
boku
p qu and da most true PewDiePie watched
boku no pico yeah he watched it people
watch it for like for like the cringe
but I wouldn't even watch it word
absalom i'm way too vanilla for that
stuff I'm sorry um Oh someone in the
chat said big order I don't know if you
have you guys what's the big overhaul
but yeah I tried I tried to watch some
of it and it just seems stupid well is
trash and yes it was by the author who
did me tiny ki future diary if you guys
watched future times yeah you know gasai
the crazy ex yonder I didn't like big
order it was so cliche it was trash I
didn't like the plot of the story it was
not going anywhere for me yeah I didn't
what how how is um like stands like a
bullet you thing worked I didn't I
didn't like it like it just basically
stabs them and then does it and you know
that they under his control as much as
even like with the girl like she hates
the guy you know you can see that she
hates the guy and then as soon as like
she gets within a certain range of him
they say oh yeah I love him yummy and it
was like oh god this is yeah this wit I
mean if she wants to kill him all she
has to do is be like so many hundred
yards away sniper rifle bang over there
we go yeah yeah yeah it was stupid it
really was yeah here's how I heard about
Big Oil like the first one that came out
was actually the OVA when I watch the
old way I was like can this use looks
good and this girl definitely looked
like the young looked like a yandere
there wasn't like big things happening
in their boat was so interesting and
when the series got released and I
started to watch it episode after
episode I was like okay it's not going
anywhere
I just I just like forced myself to
watch it at the end in my anime list
actually got probably a 5 point
something rating very very low rating
first series I would say it wasn't the
best work anyone has made by the way
Master of Puppets says yuria nice
fanbase is like 98% women it's probably
not quite 98 percent but I will tell you
that one uri a nice video that we made
just like a news video talking about
whether a season 2 is coming was over
90% women like you can see in YouTube's
statistics and it was over 90% women
watching it and in
our other videos it's mostly men
watching it so yeah definitely for your
nice
it's a vast majority women watching it
um if you Jonesy power is strong yeah
somewhat somewhat uh oh yeah snore Lee a
gay deep voice over there he said that I
better not hate on my hero academia in
this stream he said you better hate on
my hero academia well one thing I
actually noticed I realized something
recently and I hate to admit this okay
well no I don't hate a minute I don't
actually dislike the show my hero
academia I dislike two characters but
there are two main characters and that's
deku and Bakura I dislike those guys
because I realized even though I want to
hear the show because of those two guys
I can because I think Todoroki is a very
cool character I really like his
backstory I think that um some of the
villains are really cool they I think
Veronica is very cool as well so I like
I feel like I can't hate on the show as
a whole but I definitely like Deku and
Bosco and it's because the two of them
are such cliche hero and you know kind
of rival like Bakugan is basically or
Vegeta
you're freaking um what's a scary yugioh
you're you know like the he's the guy
he's you're such a cliche you know like
tsundere male rival Gary from Pokemon
and then you have Deku who is your you
know such a classic underdog but then
somehow becomes Opie off you know
magically and then now he's you know
your classic Naruto you're you know just
just to cliche so those two characters I
dislike but overall I have to say the
show us some really cool concepts and
really cool characters and of course
giant girl is just best girl I would say
Jon girl's best girl for me I would say
Invisible Girl is investigating her name
is mouth lady mouth lady is a beautiful
lady and there's so much of her I love
it
oh you gotta respect Momo Invisible Girl
is best yeah Momo yeah yeah I love
Momo's or she's not through yeah I don't
know I mean I like also the strategy
side of dekhi I think that's good how
you see how he's got like all those like
books upon books or strategies that he's
worked out from watching like heroes
fight and stuff like that Eva strategies
against our heroes or strategies of what
to do in certain situations by learning
from heroes you know I liked that kind
of side of him stuff you know I mean
they make a joke out of it as well where
he does like his crazy ramblings to
himself and everyone kind of gets
creeped out but you know I was good it
was different because a lot of Shonen
you never see like a strategy side to it
like you you never see it a strategic
fight from luffy you know he'd never do
that you know he's just gonna clash
strength against strength and he's gonna
overpower but yeah Decco is he's just
completely different it's just a new
thing yeah I mean well not really a new
thing because there are vus shows
they've touched on things like that but
it's good to see that come back yeah
like it I I guess your point but like
for example I just like that stuff much
morning like Code Geass or death no
that's type of strategy then though and
we see with Deku but um the RZA says he
wants a shout out and I'm just gonna say
that the wu-tang Clan ain't nothing to
[ __ ] with me oh nice Imperials the pins
like Anna Mac is a great man for
admitting his mistakes well it's not
easy but like I said I can't like stain
looks really cool like a really cool
girl but he actually has motivation
behind what he's doing and like he has a
point of all the you know corruption of
modern societies up yeah like I like
that kind of stuff so yeah I'm not kind
of enemy like he's not just like you
know one dimension on it I'm the big bad
guy that's it
I hate you guys and that's it you know
he actually has like a good like a like
ideology behind him yeah I mean which is
you know this is good what would you
guys think about hinge
angers O&F with my seen a few people in
the Chad mentioned hand shakers I only
saw one episode because we actually did
a foreign cyanide Blizzard's channel
first impressions of hand shakers
I saw the one episode and you know I was
like what is this it was it was so great
like the art like the backgrounds are
more interesting than the actual
characters which is obviously very
distracting and weird the whole concept
of hand of the hand shakers is so
insufficient like inefficient like
what's going on how do they go to the
bathroom you know how come holding hands
how come how come Tom what about our
names like the bondage to the bondage
twins what a name whipping something
[ __ ] if I forgot their names it's been a
quite a while but yeah so they they
don't have to be connected by their
hands but these guys are like and the
only thing that I foundation about that
show is that is the blatant edgy with
the chick like with the salad with the
sad though masochism but he just watch
scenes with her in it and close your
eyes and guess what type of anime you
wanna what the girl has like the bouncy
boobs people what type of anime you're
watching if you look just just
literature no don't encourage we come to
do dynamic don't know I would not do
that but a lot of people were saying
like oh my god I'm getting a seizure
it's too much for me I don't mind that I
mean I I don't I don't [ __ ] get
seizures from watching like these
schools that's happening in the
background was really actually pretty
pretty dope for me the most bad thing
about the series was actually the plot
itself is very confusing very confusing
at point I didn't understand what was
going on at points there was like some X
scenes that were unnecessary to have in
there as I quiet why would you have a
[ __ ] bath scene in there it's just so
unnecessary you don't need that that
brought the series a little bit down
yeah similar God and that blows my mind
no I really because that's how I felt
about it this was like so understand
and I had a similar view also about
clockwork planet again I saw the first
episode to see if I would want to watch
more and yeah it was just like in your
face
unnecessary contrived HG the world
didn't really make sense they didn't
pinger [ __ ] this is he yeah yeah yeah
like what was like that was so
unnecessary in the first episode and in
the world they didn't take any time to
actually build the world to make it
interesting they're just like finger
[ __ ] like yeah but that's exactly
what happened in the manga if you didn't
know well doesn't matter it's just not
like yeah yeah you're still bad taste
that's daughter - uh-huh and it was
super convenient how she just ended up
to land in his bedroom I mean I oh come
on he didn't have to journey anywhere to
find her I just wake up no yeah no yeah
that was some dream
don't hang people some people are
calling in the chat they're calling out
Aaron for getting beat up by Annie come
on guys okay that's an awesome yeah
anyway highly trained Raina got by I
mean yeah Annie is a highly trained
hand-to-hand combat fighter okay so stop
laughing at them they're like Aaron get
that girl come on come on yep I mean
then any did something like teaching him
exactly how to [ __ ] wrestle someone
bound yeah I think I see it well I don't
well that was used on the armored Titan
that was sick that at any time that was
legit awesome I used to love to lean on
the item the training hand-to-hand
combat then they have Annie and Aaron
fighting as Titans like that then they
have Aaron and on the armored Titan
fighting as Titans like that I thought I
was very very cool how they like the
more Aaron can actually control his
Titan the more like we see like fighting
techniques coming into play it's cool it
was clearly an inspired by MMA I think
yeah I like Muay Thai stance - then her
like ground game as well like you know I
have a greco-roman wrestling or
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu you know so yeah
that goes that goes on in the latest a
female Titan explained video talked
about how the style that any uses is
similar to muy Thai mmm there was no
there was a scene
we're Annie and Mikasa then went up to
fight but unfortunately then show it I
was ok I wish we could leave a fight I
wish we could see them fight who do you
think would win though I'm a minister
forever I love I was saying yes I love I
love because I think I mean with the one
I don't know mica sauce my girl man mica
so yeah oh because it's strong and stuff
but is she technical that's the that's
the question well I was bet I would bet
I'll make a sir any day just because I
love her she's the belle okay I hear
that on deep voice is talking about
Tokyo ghoul yeah I personally really
dislike Tokyo ghoul the anime again
people tell me that the manga is much
better but I hated it it was just so
edgy for the sake of being edgy it was
like tumblr made into an anime like the
oldest like these people getting
sexually attracted the concept of
cannibalism and just like hurting people
for the sake of hurting and enjoying and
getting aroused from that like it was
still soul it was so bad like Tokyo
ghouls so bad oh god yeah the first the
first season was like if you if your
manga reader than the first season was
was just about bearable the second
season was atrocious it was it was
terrible it was like all made up pretty
much except for like the first episode
but then even that fight that's in the
first episode got really cut short and
done badly and after that it just like
downward spiral to stupidness and yeah I
dropped that yeah yeah uh
z-9 says opening was good yeah for sure
opening was good but that was the only
thing I like Kareena said she liked
Tokyo ghoul well yeah I only got through
like six episodes me and goes and watch
it together and when they brought that
gourmet guy back after he was clearly
killed we were like that we're done
we're done dropping it dropped me hard
also review times he's like can anyone
see me typing we see you bro
also I think you said oh hey Lelouch at
some point so definitely all hail
Lelouch to you ah well I do get by yeah
yeah do you hear that adamak oh my god
you can hear the Dragons roar you can
you hear the Dragons roar it's my boy
not
from fairytale yeah you can easily take
down the launch man fairytale bro is a
great enemy that people love to hate on
what oh yeah I love yeah a lot of people
hang out to me I don't I don't feel that
it should be hate it it's such a good
series I've lost everything I'm caught
up to it I'm still waiting to watch a
fairy tale dragon cry it's it's still
not out on any any side so I'm so with
the thing that surprises me is the fairy
tale gets hey well seven deadly sins
don't let them hurt the same because
it's shorter and well better executed I
feel like if some new license keeps on
going like I read the manga I enjoy but
we keep on going to the anime it doesn't
get adapted well it could turn into
another fairy tale like I enjoyed fairy
tale for like a little bit and then I
got bored
I dropped the show twice at 100 episodes
I rewatched the first 100 episodes twice
which is so random there was too much
time between I need to restart stuff in
the beginning yeah I watched like the
first like 30-something episodes and I
stopped kind of because it ended up
being the same thing like I'm not saying
the characters are bad there's
interesting stuff Lucy heirs are
interesting characters to me but like
Lucy has an interesting backstory too
but it was just like you know with the
enemies like you know they keep coming
no one dies nothing no consequences for
actions that kind of stuff are kind of
tired me out with the seven deadly sins
you tonight a similar argument but I
think that certainly sends us better
humor which keeps me watching and also
like like break said it's shorter so
it's like you don't get bored as quickly
because it's like there's not that much
of it there are some stuff that happens
our characters who actually a die in
just a beer and when we get the
Commission like 500 episodes in fairy
tale like I feel like I watched the
hundred episodes I feel like Bob suit
didn't like he didn't get to that like
stronger I'd like you would learn a new
move or learn techniques to defeat an
enemy and then the next fight is
completely forget about it no no way too
much yeah that's when you're wrong
because he does get stronger because at
the end of the of the of the fair within
the first first hundred episodes I
thought he didn't get strong okay catch
why here's what I'm gonna tell you
before the film fair trial fairy tale a
dragon crying at the end of the series
not not so actually
off without telling anyone and then he
came back and he was even more powerful
than you could ever imagine and he could
be he was even more powerful after he
came back I was actually really I was
actually so glad because that was when a
fairytale the whole entire guild
actually separated their ways and went
on and then he came back and the
continuation is in dragon crime of
course I haven't watched it so I don't
know what happens well that's good to
hear at least he doesn't get like
stronger in some way well it's for sure
killer ed says he he thinks that fairy
tale has [ __ ] plot [ __ ] arcs [ __ ]
character development [ __ ] writing the
only thing it's good for his hentai
artists yeah yeah that's right that's
right that's why I agree hey oh my god
Oh young the big seller no I think I
think um I think with with fairy tale is
like you can't take it too serious I
guess if you're looking for like a
serious series with characters you
really wanna like get into say like how
um how that one pieces yeah
or nooooo what it's not it's not like
that you know you can't really connect
to those characters to to toughen it up
yeah I mean it's just small you're just
watching a show more first and
attainment volume so for me when I look
at it like that is you know it's alright
yeah there's gonna be dumb things yeah
the good guys are gonna win yeah I mean
yeah I don't expect the good guys to
really die yeah I mean when you think of
it that kind of childish just
entertainment level then yeah you can
get through it no problem yeah but when
you're hoping for more because also you
people I guess well this generation it
would have grown up with the drug boozy
people dying and stuff with the new rule
one piece and then from there that then
come across fairytale expecting
something along those lines then yeah
obviously disappointment other question
for salt water okay go ahead Anna back
was a ukx task or says the fairy tale
was what got him into anime so he kind
of appreciates it and I feel like yeah
like a lot of these popular anime that
you know they have a lot of faults did
get a lot of people into anime then they
discover that there's more to anime than
just the top popular mainstream series
so that is something as well um what
else I wanted to address oh yeah Babur
gorgeous he keeps asking about the full
metal alchemist 2003 version and I
actually didn't see that version because
I really got it trending around 2010 and
when I was deciding whether to watch to
watch full metal alchemist people told
me don't just skip the 2003 one watch
Brotherhood so that's the one I ended up
watching and I absolutely loved it so
it's like my top 3 and I'm a ol time so
I can't speak to the other one and I
almost don't want to watch the other one
because I don't want to ruin my
experience with Brotherhood because a
lot of people say that the other one is
not as good so no I thought I think 2003
was good it was better in my eyes but
it's just the ending wasn't as good
that's all that's exactly you I have a
similar stance I think they're both good
I think Brotherhood is slightly better
just like towards like the second half
what I recommend people to do is to
watch the first 10 episodes of the
original and then move on because they
do a better time like I guess developing
Edward and Alphonse backstory and stuff
like that I think it was very rushed in
Brotherhood and then it got better after
that because like they assumed you had
already watched the original both great
series though no hey arm because if you
watch if you read the manga that would
have you know you would have known I
like um Aaron is saying surprisingly
attack on Titan it's a great anime and I
agree but I think that another great
thing when tagging time is the manga
like the manga is really good actually
I'm reading the manga beyond the enemy
now soul I hope you're happy
and I good good and it's yeah I really
enjoy it because it's even like when I
watched the first season of attack on
Titan I thought near the middle it got
the pacing got slow it's like they were
stretching it out but if you read the
manga it's much more fast paced like
they get right to the point they don't
spend you know there's not filler at all
so I I thought I think that the manga
and the anime are
good not just the enemy I have to say
yeah I used to like to kind of hate on
the enemy a little bit because I really
enjoyed it at the beginning and then I
felt like the pacing slowed down and I
never had any like affection for any of
the characters I didn't really care
about the characters so one characters
died I didn't have like that feeling for
them but I can't hate it on him anymore
because I love season 2 it was great
yeah and Myka saw me cuz I always liked
and actually reading the manga i mean i
maybe i have to re-watch the first
season for reading the manga I liked
Aaron a lot more than I did
watching the first season and like when
you realize like how you know committed
he is how devoted to his cause to his
goal he's ready to go you know he's
ready to fight he doesn't care and he
doesn't cry about it he goes and he
fights and you know he he does what it
takes I love that about him saw Aaron
even though he's not the smartest dude
he is you know he is a respectable
respectable guy I really appreciate I
think people under undervalue Aaron as a
character because I feel like yeah maybe
he's too quick and impulsive but it's
because he believes so much and what he
wants to do to achieve and I feel like
the people that do believe and take
risks and do sometimes stupid stuff is
the people that really get things done
and succeed in life so yeah I respect
Aaron love Mikasa Levi is just a cool
badass urban badass as well so there
sasha is hilarious saw that there's a
lot of I think Erik ters in a type of
thing that once you get into it you can
really start caring about I'm for me for
for me concerning Aaron the only issue I
have with Aaron is basically he's
nothing without his power yeah I mean
like recently season two he just got his
first tie and kill you know like without
his power and yeah it's like if he never
had his power then you just be like that
guy who's hot-headed but first one into
a fight but also the first to get taken
home yeah ain't so yeah but books you
won't talk to me something oh I wanted
to ask you why do you like to hate on
one piece haha really it's like also we
believe in finally what the epsilon
and obviously won't be so pair
yourselves guys nice well I hate you go
for me
Polly did the problem with one piece is
like the thing that would solve it is if
one piece was like one punch one yet
that been the there's no actual overall
goal you know and then it's just like a
day-in-the-life adventure after
adventure in it there's no rule like
goal to go towards or look towards but
with one piece there is and the fact
that you're now 700 and something
episodes 800 and some chapters in and
you can't tell me like anytime dirt like
Goofy's gone okay we are going over here
because that's why the one pieces or I
hear that one pieces over here so let's
go over there that makes it a problem
for me because it's like he's he's like
consciously avoiding the plot yummy just
to drag this story oh my evil and shop
was with Raley and he and he said like
Tralee oh oh he'll know where the one
piece is hey Bailey do you know where
and then like luffy cracked open it you
start to music no don't if you find out
then I'm stopping this journey now yeah
me I think was like wow that wasn't
awesome seemed like I miss you this like
there's no and that's the thing like
there's a end goal like there's there's
like the one piece he wants to find
obviously but like that's not really the
point the point is he wants to go on his
grand adventure and it's kind of the one
piece is just there to like give a
meaning to the 850 episodes but like
honestly if there was no one piece at
the end I think I wouldn't even beat
that like heartbroken because like he
said with really like Railly knows where
the one piece is and knows about the one
piece and he was of like Gustav was
asking about any luffy's like shut the
hell up if you tell me where like if I
find know anything about the one piece
on what's the called I mean this journey
right now because the whole because that
would ruin his journey the whole point
is going on an adventure to spend
friends and finally get together not
having someone tell you where it is you
know oh man imagine if they do after all
those episodes after all those manga
chapters imagine if they do the wizard
baaz anything it's like the one piece
was in your heart the whole time
exactly exactly oh they open up a chest
and as a piece of paper with the IOU
yeah I make this I'm gonna tell you the
top reason why new people who are new 10
main they have they haven't even watched
one piece yet why you should not watch
fun piece first of all it is too damn
long it's like 700 episodes in that
would take you about probably two years
or a year and something to at least
catch up and probably be the best two
years of your life but okay probably
yeah and there are brand new anime
seasons coming out all the stuff and you
have to like you have to pile them up
with one piece and it will be too much
for you
so I would say it is probably the best
thing to do is stay away from one piece
you stop I need to I need to address a
juror the hero because you said so Mike
is it basically if you like one of the
other Shonen like the moooo
you have to be ante one piece I would
say form like the manga fandom aspect I
have seen that especially from like the
bleach crowd definitely um but for me
personally no old all of the big free to
me were terrible I don't like any of
them the bleach was like super rush
towards the end ichigo had no character
development every time you come across a
new enemy it was like copy and paste
their abilities fighting shinik
Shinigami he gets a bank i - he's
fighting the hollow he's using hollow
power - he's fighting quincy he gets
quincy power - he's fighting full brain
he gets full bun - yeah it's very like
poor nooooo was just too strong with
that bromance I'm sorry that was like
madama chasing after hashirama for his
would in his DNA and yet no there's so
many like gay innuendos in it that yeah
it was just like it was waiting for them
means the way that series himself and
for me one piece the whole problem I
have one piece is like the
avoidance of that grant goal yeah I mean
that's where I'm just like now yeah I
mean if there was like a steady right
thing of like maybe something getting
mentioned about every I don't know 10
chapters 10 episodes whatever then I
would feel they're okay we are making
progress towards that grand plot as well
cuz right now it just feels like okay
we're journey in here because you
chasing after nami
then we're journeying over here cuz that
means sick then you know we're going
over here because you need to help her
vivy and yummie it's just like a light
day after day a new adventure but with
no real direction to it yeah I mean I
agree with you like the one piece isn't
the biggest deal to Luffy like he also
obvi you want to be by a king he wants
to one piece with more about the
adventure to him and going from island
to island though to counter that a
little bit
you always are making progress because
we have learned that the one pieces at
the end of the grand line so essentially
you need to like sail the entire world
or the entire Grand Line in New World um
so you know like he's going from island
to island he's getting closer it's like
the reason why it's such a long journey
he's basically like traversing most of
the world yeah yeah got Hinda a meaty I
mean I see that that basically serves
the purpose of Nami really that's who
that serves that serves Nami because she
wants to do the world mapping so like
her goal is achieved by this journey of
grind everywhere but I mean I can see
that some people may say oh the journey
has to be like this because then all the
members their individual goals get like
achieved by the end but the thing is
series don't have to be like that like
you could have it like end with them
like getting there and then after like a
little like epilogue episode chapter
whatever and then you see Nami Dan and
now she's drawn her world map she's
finally finished it you know there's no
Zoro with that marine girl and you know
they're together Sam
opened up a school you know whatever you
know that you don't always need to have
everything finished by the end you can
still like come to
an end of the main story and then show
an epilogue you know so yeah I wouldn't
want that in that way but I'm also a
very hardcore fan um to answer what
anime recon was saying for like
newcomers it's definitely very hard to
get into one piece now like this 850
chapters or something um I would say
that it's worth the time but it's a very
huge commitment it's hard to commit to
that of course like he said if I take
two years probably best to unity real
life uh uh but away many anime dude shut
up to the anime dude he is here and our
boy pea bacon said that he can get into
one piece again because it's too long
and he also says that he's having
problems getting into my hero academia
and like I said I feel similarly about
my hair claim eeeh but the thing that
really like recently has spoken to me in
my area is things like total Iraqis
backstory I thought that was really well
done I think Todoroki is a really cool
character I like dark shadow the quirk
too I think is a very interesting quirk
arm the whole concept of not being able
to control it things like that
I like Baraka I like the villain stain
right so I'm my hero academia kind of
wins me over
despite deku and baku go being annoying
to me because of the other stuff and I
like I always say in the first season
the most interesting stuff to me in my
hero academia was the final arc when the
villains arrived the whole training and
stuff with deck wasn't that interested
in me but when the villains showed up I
was like man this is intense I was like
those like three episodes at the end I
was like man this is crazy
so it's like that show has its moments
but I think its weaknesses are the two
main characters being buck row and deku
and their little rivalry like I don't
care like it's too cliche it's too Goku
Vegeta Naruto Sasuke like we've seen it
Gary Ashe yeah you're right
I mean next week it's gonna be the brand
new arc because of course as we all know
the sports festival arc is now over so
um yeah we're moving on now but what I
want to say the most is that a lot of
people watch like one
these fairy tale of Naruto many people
watch 3 many people watch two people
watch one but the main reason why I do
not like one piece it is because I feel
it's being mentioned a lot more lately
than fairy tale like it's getting so
much height one piece
cuz it's better no it's not was is
theone II know it's this long that's why
but it's the only surviving big free
that's why yeah I mean does this none
does not the big free left no I was
finished I meet is called boooo but
whose coconuts we were but um yeah and
then honestly bleach finished in a bad
way but um but not not for the anime
fans obviously cuz you know and my fans
I had a decent dish and I guess cuz it
seemed pretty clean how it ended maybe
people would want it a bit more you know
um but yeah so yeah I mean it's the only
one left
Fairy Tail was never a big freak it was
never a big three was never big freaking
tender I mean it did get popular a time
but then once as a popped out that
freaking I don't know Jesus armor which
could bend the rules of magic that's
when lots of people like ok forget this
and I started dropping off and then
after that any other members that were
left when they got to the sting and
rogue fight against Nazi and how
ridiculous that ended yeah
lot of people dropped off there as oh no
just like no no no this is just stupid
cuz he didn't even beat them in a fight
they basically saw how strong he was and
then like they just were like fell to
their knees and cried and the fight was
over and it was just like well okay this
is [ __ ] but yeah so yeah that's my
fault anyway
thank you so by the way all I'm not is
not one piece is better continue
ultimate need says that he got his
coworker to watch Code Geass good work
good work
nicely done goal stalker asks is it
about time to wrap things up and I think
it is we can slowly start wrapping
things up everybody but by the way if
you want to continue the conversation
you can always join our discord server
link in the description we tried there
pretty much all day someone's on having
fun chatting all sorts of different chat
rooms available for whatever interest
you and soul maka is there doing this
thing educating everyone about the
importance of manga we have
manga recommendations an America
commitment they exactly on this Court
it's a great time before we go though
enemy recon tell us who you are and what
you do and why you love sort out all on
oh all right how's it going fans ruled
my name is Amir recon and I do daily
live reactions and of course enemy top
tends to give you guys my first
impressions and you know um
recommendations of what enemy you should
watch and whether this enemy is worth
your time to watch but why like sorta
online is because my boy Quito is my
favorite and he is so o P that just
drives me to the series I just love the
series overall because the plot is
interesting
my favorite arc is the gun Gale online
arc and I loved I really enjoyed the
movie ok well thanks a good series
thanks recon common is infinitely better
than Kirito in every way but I know
she's not harutora
by the way shout out to him and shout
about yeah yeah over there we see arm in
an errand talking about getting together
in time in discord just talking real
life you guys are friends um all the
breaks tripled the anime what who are
you what do you do my friend
all-day anime I make explained and fact
videos you know just look things you
wouldn't already know about characters
in series like you know my hero academia
add an act savored anime I can explain
stuff like people's quirks or
one-for-all explained the transfer book
work that all my pass down to um yuzu ku
me Toria on or I'll mess up his name
there for a second but yeah back videos
explain videos all the things come check
me out if you'd like one piece rules
[ __ ] one piece hahaha you lightning
darken your cool animal part thank you
very much and so tell us who you are and
what you do
hi everybody I'm so maka I am a hentai
artist and I am on this code all the
time every day pretty much
and yeah I'm always there to talk
discuss debate manga and anime as well
as I try to keep people informed as all
with less Anime News yeah so minded can
you show me one of your drawings when we
need a question yeah well you have
private yeah so Marcus a national
discord what I want to tell you so like
a publicly thank you for all the hard
work you do on this court it's much
appreciated it's no wonder that you're a
Viceroy over there
it's no wonder yeah yeah I understand
thank you very much having faith in my
ability guys but this will be uploaded
in its entirety on the channel we have a
playlist for enter phase they're all
uploaded there we do it every week on
Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
so join us live
watch afterwards comment love to have
you as part of the community we talk
about different topics in anime have
different guests it's always a great
time and you can join a discord server
as well link in the description where
you can chat with us daily
thank you everyone in the chat who was
with us hanging out thank you for to my
guests and until next time see a space
cowboys bang I love you on shin Baku